[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the first eight episodes of
yellowjackets i will be doing detailed
reviews for episode nine and ten i
thought here i'll just catch you guys up
on everything i thought about the show
because i haven't been able to review it
i've been busy with other shows but i'm
so excited to jump into yellow jackets
because i've absolutely
adored this show and there's certain
reasons why i love it but it's actually
the most love coming from a place of as
a fan where
just as a fan of someone who loves tv
mysteries
this is something i've been waiting for
for a while it has that feeling of
excitement with lost where you can
call friends family members talk about
it go on reddit and you see the power of
this show is that
the amount of people on reddit for the
yellow jackets is already at like 15 000
people which is unheard of because
there's shows on tv that premiered maybe
three years ago that three seasons and
they're still only at like 6 000 people
on reddit so it's that kind of show
people want to talk about and theorize
and the strength and excitement these
kind of mysteries bring is because it's
not based off a book so it's so annoying
is a lot of tv mysteries that come out
are based off a book so you got book
readers who can just spoil the ending
and also it just kills the theory
conversation we can have on these
threads what's so great about this show
as well is that it has powerhouse
performances by its leads and shout out
juliette lewis of course i interviewed
her a year ago check that interview out
i'll link at the end of this but
yes she's amazing christina richie
amazing melanie linski amazing and i
hope i'm not butchering her name but
tawny cyprus who plays
taissa
is a show stealer here i am so impressed
by all four of them playing the roles of
the leads but that's not to undermine
how great the younger actors are and the
younger versions of these characters now
when i'm looking at it per episode base
it's not perfect and
you can tell even that feeling of the
community had where
it has such a good premiere and if you
haven't seen it you know check it out on
youtube the first episode is free it
will suck you in with that great reveal
at the end with misty and you're seeing
this image of just this lord of the
flies like area where you're like how do
we get to this and that's what makes it
so exciting is right like
what are these people now and how are
they in the past and then who are they
really we're just taking pieces together
learning more more about our characters
through the past and through the future
so you're excited to get this little
tease of where this show ends up we know
it's five seasons but
what's interesting is that
after episode one i did think it hit a
little bit of a lull where it was way
too slow and i think the lowest point
this show got to was actually episode
four which i actually did not like it's
only episode i didn't enjoy at all um
because we had
shauna on this date with adam for like
half the episode to the point like do we
need this much screen time between the
two of them how much is this serving the
plot it just felt like a lot of padding
has been put in the show the whole
season but where i think people start
getting worried was after episode four
you can even see like okay you know we
need something to happen but
you know episode five it picks up a bit
but really the other two episodes i've
loved are episode six where
we get the reveal of taissa now is
crawling eating dirt which was just
insane but also my favorite was episode
seven again based in taies's story but
with van and the wolves it was so
powerful it was intense it was kind of
that savagery we're waiting for that
brutalness and
i think episode 8 the most recent one
fell flat again which was disappointing
because i hoped it was going to keep
that momentum going it's still good but
again i feel like this shows has these
brilliant episodes of one six and seven
where the rest is okay and i hope that
in season two they can tighten it up
less padding and i think yeah obviously
people want to see as much as possible
of them when they're in the woods as
kids that's the exciting part it's
always going to be the most exciting
part i think they know that but they got
to stretch some story out it seems like
but again overall
what's standing out to me is again the
mystery aspect of this but the score is
absolutely bonkers and not just the
score right also the music selection the
songs they pick is great so you just
have a score and you have all these
great songs from the past playing mesh
together it's so good and it elevates so
much of this show now the big mystery
everyone has which gets everyone excited
about who is the antler queen i'm still
in the boat of lottie but that was a lot
based on the religious girl who just
died which shocks me by the way laura
lee that i thought laura lee was just
going to be that voice in lottie's head
encouraging her about her visions and
that this would start this kind of
crazy group that the underqueen leads i
thought that would be lottie because of
that so you know with laura lee dying
which shocked me i was actually very
interested in her character it doesn't
mean we're not going to see her in other
ways and flashbacks and stuff but i did
think she'd be a bigger part of this
puzzle especially with the religious
upbringing now i'm a huge you know if we
got teams i love jackie i hate to say it
but i do i think she's great and i find
myself siding with her a lot against
shauna and i feel like shawn has just
portrayed her horribly so yes jackie was
being insanely passive aggressive and
awful to shauna but rightfully so shauna
because she's you know sleeping with her
girls guy come on now but you know it's
just that mystery again of like are what
are we seeing on the surface and what's
going on behind it what's really the
deal with missy what's really to deal
with nat all these things blending so
well together and as a whole i think i
would give the show points wise for the
season so far i'd give it about an 8.6
and that's on the strength of those big
episodes the mystery so effective the
acting the score in particular is almost
perfect and great music selection as
well and
i think that it
has to a story like this it's gonna have
a great nine and ten i could just feel
it the final two episodes to set up the
story and it's exciting to see again a
mystery story that's planned out for
five seasons not based off a book so i'm
excited to see where this goes i'm
really pumped and i feel that energy
from this fan base so that excites me
but like i said i promise i'll be able
to do a more detailed review for episode
9 and episode 10 so please make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss those
reviews and please follow me at steve
all the show on twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me
and i'll see you next time